[Música]
es un gusto saludarlos Soy Paula Jiménez
Correa y les doy la bienvenida Así es
Asia el magazine de France 24 que acerca
la realidad de este continente a América
Latina Y a partir de hoy los estaré
acompañando cada dos semanas para
mostrarles el día a día de su población
Estos son nuestros titulares
en medio de una gran polémica Japón
despidió al ex Primer Ministro Jean
suave en un funeral de estado
cuestionado por los más de 11,5 millones
de dólares que costó a la ceremonia
asistieron más de 4000 personas
devastación y graves daños a la
estructura son el saldo que deja el paso
del tifón norum por filipinas además de
10 personas perdieron la vida Vietnam y
Tailandia también sufrieron los embates
del fenómeno natural más potente
registrado en los últimos años
veto a los conciertos en Hong Kong a
medida que la vida nocturna regresa
después de las restricciones por el
covid 19 algunos músicos se sienten
relegados e incluso discriminados debido
a que se mantiene la prohibición de
presentaciones en vivo en bares y
restaurantes
iniciamos este recorrido por el
continente asiático en Japón que celebró
el funeral de estado del Primer Ministro
suave asesinado el pasado 8 de julio a
manos de un hombre que le disparó en un
mitín político el evento al que
asistieron más de 4000 personas no
estuvo exento de la polémica por su
elevado costo en plena crisis económica
los altos niveles de inflación que se
registran en el país
con flores oraciones y un saludo de 19
salvas Japón honró al ex Primer Ministro
asesinado chinzoave en el primer funeral
de estado de un ex Primer Ministro en 55
años
una ceremonia que se ha vuelto tan
controvertida como lo fue él en vida
[Música]
y no significativamente más fuerte la
relación con Estados Unidos fortaleció
drásticamente el poder de disuasión
entre Japón y Estados Unidos mejoró la
cooperación entre India y Australia para
crear el marco quad una aspiración de
larga Data que siempre tuvo amigo
su diplomacia de múltiples niveles ha
creado buenas relaciones con todas las
regiones del mundo
delegaciones de más de 200 países varios
líderes mundiales representantes y
organismos internacionales entre otros
invitados estuvieron entre los más de
4000 asistentes a la ceremonia del
Primer Ministro con más años en
funciones en la historia de Japón
los ciudadanos también tuvieron la
oportunidad de despedir al ex Primer
Ministro cuyo mandato duró casi 10 años
Es realmente frustrante que lo
asesinaran y nos dejara
estoy así esperaba que pudiera servir
como nuestro Primer Ministro por tercera
vez así que vine a ofrecerle flores y
expresarle mis condolencias
pero en otras áreas de Tokio la capital
japonesa miles de personas manifestaban
su malestar contra los 11,5 millones de
dólares que costó el funeral de estado
para Jean suave dinero pagado por los
contribuyentes
varias encuestas indicaban que el 60% de
Los japoneses se oponían a la ceremonia
y que el 75%, opinaba que el gobierno
estaba gastando demasiado en el funeral
cometió actos delictivos y abusó de su
poder político celebraron funeral de
estado para una persona así es un error
escandaloso
el asesinato de ave en un mitin de
campaña el pasado 8 de julio desencadenó
una avalancha de revelaciones sobre los
vínculos entre los legisladores del
gobernante partido liberal democrático
que habe una vez dirigió y la iglesia de
la unificación que los críticos llaman
una secta hecho que ha provocado una
reacción violenta contra el actual
Primer Ministro fumeo quichida
no durante su visita a Japón la
vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos camela
Harris reiteró el apoyo a Taiwán en su
autodefensa hacia china Harris condenó
las acciones inquietantes de China y
habló de provocaciones en el estrecho de
Taiwán las palabras y el viaje de Harris
a Asia se producen días después de que
el presidente de Estados Unidos
reiterará su compromiso de defender a
Taiwán en caso de una invasión china
recordemos que la atención entre Beijing
y Washington incremento en agosto tras
la visita de la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes de Estados Unidos
Nancy pelosi a Taiwán territorio que
china considera como suyo
Estados Unidos cree que la paz y la
estabilidad en el estrecho de Taiwán es
una característica esencial de un Indo
Pacífico libre y abierto
y continuaremos volando navegando y
operando sin miedo
Dónde y cuándo el derecho internacional
lo permite
El paso del tifón noru por varios países
del sur asiático dejó destrucción y
profundos daños en miles de estructuras
sin contar las pérdidas humanas Pues
solo en Filipinas se reportaron más de
10 fallecidos y varios desaparecidos
Vietnam y Tailandia también fueron
Víctimas de los embates de este fenómeno
natural
devastación es lo que quedó a su paso
del tifón noru por el sur de Asia
estas imágenes aéreas dan cuenta de las
graves inundaciones registradas en
varias áreas del norte de Filipinas el
país más afectado por el fenómeno
natural el consejo de emergencias
nacional reportó fallecidos en las
provincias de rizal sambales que son y
bulacán todas ellas en la isla de luzón
donde Naruto Tierra como super tifón Con
vientos sostenidos de hasta 250
kilómetros por hora según datos del
servicio meteorológico filipino
San Miguel Esta es la peor inundación
que ha ocurrido aquí en San Miguel mi
casa en formal y gaia tiene dos niveles
y el agua llegó hasta el segundo piso
incluso nuestro mercado local quedó
completamente sumergido
entre los fallecidos por el tifón además
de civiles se encuentran miembros de los
diversos equipos de rescate cuyos
cuerpos fueron arrasados por las aguas
mientras trataban de evacuar a cientos
de personas de un barrio en la población
de San Miguel de bulacán donde se
desbordó
se estima que cerca de 700.000 personas
fueron afectadas por nuru varias de
ellas siguen en los albergues
establecidos por los autoridades sin
saber hasta cuándo podrán regresar a sus
hogares las pérdidas en infraestructura
se estima en unos 400 mil dólares
mientras que el 75% de los cultivos de
arroz en la isla de luzón Se podrían ver
afectados
vietnami Tailandia también sufrieron los
embates del tifón decenas de vías
principales de varias ciudades quedaron
completamente inundadas por las intensas
lluvias y desbordamientos de ríos que
complicaron las evacuaciones y
asistencias humanitarias
vamos a China porque por primera vez en
30 años dejará de ser el motor de
crecimiento en Asia así lo ha anunciado
el Banco Mundial en su más reciente
informe en el que señala que la segunda
Economía del mundo crecerá este año por
debajo de la media de la región un 2,8%
frente al 5.3% del resto de Asia Cuáles
son las razones en gran parte se debe a
su estricta política de cobitzero que
provocaron un estancamiento económico
durante semanas y meses también se
destacan el derrumbe del mercado
inmobiliario las altas tasas de
desempleo Juvenil y el debilitamiento de
su moneda el Joan
Así es Asia y se lo contamos en France
24 Estos son otros hechos destacados que
marcan la agenda del continente
el tribunal supremo de India confirmó
que tanto las mujeres solteras como las
casadas que hayan sido Víctimas de abuso
sexual podrán interrumpirrse embarazo
hasta la semana 24 de esta manera el
alto tribunal considera inconstitucional
hacer distinciones entre mujeres
solteras y casadas para poder Acceder al
aborto
en Afganistán un grupo de mujeres se
manifestó en kabul la capital del país
frente a la embajada de Irán para unirse
al rechazo por la muerte de una joven
que se encontraba bajo custodia de la
policía de la moral iraní las fuerzas
talibanes afganas dispersaron con tiros
las marchas de las mujeres
en China un grupo de arqueólogos
descubrió en la provincia central de
juvey un cráneo fosilizado de más de un
millón de años perteneciente a la
especie homo erectus y según los
expertos es uno de los más completos e
intactos de su tipo jamás encontrados en
eurasia el cráneo fue desenterrado cerca
de la ciudad de chillán donde dos
fósiles
había sido excavados previamente en 1989
y 1990
la pandemia del coronavirus aceptó un
duro golpe a la escena de la música en
vivo en todo el mundo pero la mayoría de
los lugares ahora es posible salir a ver
un concierto pero este no es el caso en
Hong Kong donde se mantiene la
prohibición de la música en vivo en
bares y restaurantes a medida que se
reanudaron los negocios en otros
sectores de la ciudad los músicos y los
fanáticos de la música se quedaron al
margen veamos la historia de James un
Holland
no hay nada como una salida nocturna
Para escuchar música en vivo pero en
Hong Kong lo mejor que se podrá tener es
la transmisión en vivo
uno de los lugares de conciertos más
antiguos de la ciudad están haciendo
todo lo posible para mantener viva la
música Eso significa transmitir desde
este estudio a unas pocas millas de
distancia después de dos años y medio
bajo algunas de las restricciones de
covid más estrictas del mundo las bandas
aún no están permitidas en bares o
restaurantes algunos músicos sienten que
están siendo discrimina
estas medidas pandémicas han cerrado
injustamente en nuestros espacios pero
al mismo tiempo los trenes en el
transporte público las escuelas y los
restaurantes siempre están llenos de
gente Por qué los bares son el único
lugar objetivo
tienes alas de karaoke donde todavía
puedes cantar en el mismo micrófono y
propagar el virus y luego tienes lugares
de hotpot tienes restaurantes donde la
gente cena sin mascarillas y aún en un
lugar como un bar o un club no puedes
tener música en vivo realmente no tiene
ningún sentido los músicos locales han
observado desesperadamente como la vida
después del covid cobra ritmo lentamente
pero la escena de la música de pop sigue
muerta clasificada por el gobierno como
una actividad de alto riesgo
ha tenido un alto costo para los
artistas muchos se endeudaron debido a
la pérdida de ingresos y otros se vieron
obligados a empeñar sus instrumentos
[Música]
pero algunos también pueden ver un lado
positivo o quizás más exactamente un
lado artístico de la sombría situación
tener cosas tan opresivas tan bloqueadas
hará que las personas profundicen más en
su lado creativo y encuentren una
respuesta eso realmente va a hablar de
los tiempos y del futuro también
a medida que continúe el veto a los
conciertos el futuro de las bandas en
vivo Es incierto según el sindicato de
músicos de Hong Kong miles han perdido
sus trabajos o han cambiado de carrera
[Aplausos]
y para cerrar les dejo algunos datos Así
es el continente más extenso y poblado
de todo el mundo veamos esta cifras
posee aproximadamente 45 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados de área terrestre y
cuenta con más de 4,500 millones de
habitantes
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir con toda la
información en nuestra página web France
24.com continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]